[Music]
[Music]
good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster and the first
details of the queen's speech revealed
and the new laws coming our way but
what about the government's promise on
social care well the health secretary
matt hancock is on the program
shortly we'll also ask him about what's
next in our road map out of lockdown
plus the shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy is with us
as the israeli palestinian unrest
escalates
also for you this morning with
international travel about to open up
we'll be joined by the estonian
president
where vaccine passports have been rolled
out and the greek tourism minister to
ask if they'd be ready for british
tourists in june
and foodie alert the celebrity chef tom
carriage joins us to discuss
how locked down has actually changed our
eating habits
it's tuesday the 11th of may rocket fuel
the government promises big changes as
the first details of the queen's speech
are revealed
but there are questions about plans for
adult social care
calls for khan from world leaders as
israel launches airstrikes against
gaza following a palestinian rocket
attack
police charge a 21 year old man with the
murder of the police community support
officer
julia james
[Music]
and fans first we look ahead to
tonight's brit awards which will be the
first major music event in the pandemic
to have a live audience and low pressure
dominates the weather this week so
showers or longer spells of rain
continue
but not as cold as last week i'll have
the details for you later in the program
a very good morning to you the
government is promising an emphasis on
education
and training in today's queen speech the
conservatives are also expected to
announce plans to reform the asylum
system
as well as the planning system in
england well let's have a look at some
of the legislation expected in the
queen's speech today the prime minister
says the skills and post-16
education bill will act as rocket fuel
for his
leveling up agenda the law will give
every adult access to a flexible loan
for higher level education
and training the government will bring
forward the police crime
sentencing and courts bill which was
shelved last session due to violent
protests
over the powers it would give officers
in england and wales
to shut down demonstrations legally
binding targets to help tackle climate
change will be introduced in the
environment bill ahead of the uk hosting
the cop
26 summit in glasgow later this year
measures to overhaul the asylum system
and deter
people from crossing the channel are
expected in the sovereign borders bill
legislation aimed at tackling voter
fraud could mean we'll have to
produce proof of identity in order to
cast
our ballots in the future and the
cabinet office minister michael gove
said a bill on adult social care was
heading for the statute books by the end
of the year
something boris johnson has promised
reform on since becoming prime minister
in 2019. well let's talk to the health
secretary matt hancock good to see you
this morning and clearly
leveling up is is the big political push
in this queen's speech but with that in
mind wouldn't
a a specific bill on adult social care
be something that really would help
level up parts of society
well absolutely the queen's speech today
will be jam-packed
with bill's proposals to
level up the country and that's the
mission of this of this government
and that's what we're going to deliver
on you listed a few of the
areas where we're looking to legislate i
don't want to
to to preempt the words of her majesty
of course but
you know across the board across
education
across and health and social care
in terms of investment these are the
areas that we're absolutely determined
to deliver on and and
make sure that the whole country can
benefit as we recover from covid that is
the goal
but what is happening with adult social
care because it is a it is a critical
part of society we know it affects
millions of people
day in day out the prime minister 657
days ago said
he had a plan ready to implement
still nothing
well of course this is an incredibly
important area
and we're committed to bringing forward
reforms on social care we committed to
that
in our manifesto and we will be bringing
forward a
long-term plan for the reform of social
care
of course the pandemic struck a year and
a bit ago
and and we've been totally focused on
that but as we come out of kovid
so we can return to delivering on those
manifesto commitments that we've made
so so i mean we don't expect it to be
part of the queen's speech then so why
if it's so important why not
well you'll have to wait and hear what
her majesty says
you know and and you haven't heard what
she's going to say on this or indeed any
other subject but what i can tell you
is that we are committed to bringing
forward a plan
a long-term plan for the reform of adult
social care we've seen the importance of
social care through this
crisis and that has that has
in my view strengthened the need for
reform the need for integration with the
nhs
and we also need to legislate to
strengthen the nhs so that the nhs can
can build back better from covert as
well so
across the board in these areas that i'm
responsible for
and across government we'll be
delivering on the priorities on which we
were elected
and which will help us to level up and
build back from
this covert crisis and you know we're
we're lucky as a country we're
good to be in a position where we can
next week
take further steps to release some of
the measures that have been in place and
really think with this queen's speech
today about
what we need to do to build back better
from covid to learn the lessons
for instance of the success of the
vaccination program and make sure that
we can
really deliver on the commitments that
we made
yeah we'll we'll talk about the roadmap
in a minute if we may
can i can i ask why does the government
think uh
voter id is a really important issue at
the moment why are you pushing this
well we've got a a clear commitment to
make sure that when people
vote we don't have fraudulent voting
it's perfectly reasonable to ask people
to
identify who they are before doing
something as important as voting
that's yet another of our commitments
that we've made that we're delivering on
and if you think about it you know
this this government has a track record
of delivering
on our commitments we got brexit done we
protected the nhs
we're delivering on vaccination now and
the queen's speech will be
packed full of the the bills that we
will need the legislative agenda
to deliver on those commitments that we
made
in the manifesto and then what we need
to do to get this country the whole
country the whole of the uk
coming back better from from the covert
crisis i mean
look there is some concern and it's
surely you would agree legitimate
concern about some uh
groups in society uh about not having
the relevant uh photo id
at the moment i mean that's surely gonna
disenfranchise people
won't you i mean look the figures say 47
of black people don't have a driver's
license
compared to 26 of white people i mean
there is a real danger isn't there that
you
could ultimately prevent sort of key
constituents in society from from having
their say
no it's about fairness it's about making
sure that when people do something as
important as voting
then they are who they say they are
and that uh we piloted this we've looked
at it
uh in great detail we're committed to
making it happen and i think
you know people across this country want
to know for sure
that elections are fair and this is just
one measure to make the country a fairer
place but
but apparently only six cases of voter
fraud in the last election
well there's there's i i think that's
six cases too many
uh and i think that you'll find there's
very very strong support for the
principle that our elections should be
robust it's just but it's just one
example of
important changes to improve the country
to make it fairer
and uh and and then the broader leveling
up agenda which is absolutely
at the heart of the queen's speech both
in the areas i'm responsible for
uh in terms of uh the nhs um in terms of
the investment that's going in
um and in terms of making sure our
asylum laws are fairer for instance
um right across the board a whole series
of measures all about delivering on our
commitments and you know i'm acutely
aware and if you think about the
elections last week i'm acutely aware
that many places in this country have
been voting conservative for the first
time
in many many many years we've made
commitments to people
and we're absolutely determined to
deliver on those commitments
well one of the commitments that has
been made is is obviously about what's
happening
next monday the next step out of uh at a
lockdown
things seem to be going to plan which is
which is very good news but what about a
bit a bit of clarity on a few issues
first and foremost the prime minister
talked about giving people
a cautious hug last night what's one of
those
yes well it depends on people's
circumstances so
we will be changing the uh the rules
to be far more about people taking
personal responsibility
exercising common sense according to
their circumstances
and we've seen people behaving
brilliantly during the uh this pandemic
when we've asked people
to you know and intervened in ways that
we really would never want to in terms
of the social distancing measures in
terms of some of the lockdown measures
and the people have responded
brilliantly and that's one of the
reasons that we're in the position
that we are alongside of course the
vaccine rollout when it comes to
personal contact it is much safer
for two people who've had both vaccines
more than
around a fortnight ago them being in
close contact is
much safer than somebody who's been
vaccinated and somebody who hasn't or
indeed than two people who are
unvaccinated
and the the approach that we're going to
be taking
from monday is more based on personal
responsibility
we will set out really clearly the
risks people will people understand the
risks we know that
and we'll make that very very plain and
then people can exercise their own
personal responsibility so you know
grandparents sometimes for the first
time in over a year
you know will be able to be close to
their
grandchildren but of course taking into
account
the individual risk of of catching this
disease that people have which differs
according to circumstances
so you the the advice would be that i
know this may seem like a small matter
but you know people are desperate for a
hug and a cuddle
if people haven't been vaccinated then
you you would suggest
not doing that come this monday
well if two people neither of them have
been vaccinated
then of course the risk of passing on
the disease
is much higher than if they have been
vaccinated
i mean that's one of the reasons that
the vaccine program is so it's so
important it's so brilliant is that you
know it gives that
level of protection and until now we've
had blanket rules
across the board but now what we're
saying with the
prevalence of this disease so much lower
than it was
that we think trusting people's personal
responsibility is the right way to go
because those who are most at risk from
the disease
most at risk of ending up in hospital or
dying
are the vast vast majority of them are
vaccinated
over 95 percent of over 50s are now
vaccinated
and we know from the data published
yesterday that if you've had
both jabs your chances of dying from
covid are reduced by 97
these two things together the huge
uptake which is down to people turning
up
you know almost everybody over 50 has
now been jabbed it's absolutely
wonderful
the way the public's responded that
combined with the brilliant science
which gives this 97
percent protection from death if you've
had both jabs more than a fortnight ago
and the combination of these two things
means that the most vulnerable are
protected so we can
move to a a a principle
of personal responsibility when we're
totally transparent about the science of
the risks
we're clear about what that means we'll
be publishing it in really simple terms
and then allow people to do those things
that you were saying that people have
been yearning for
okay where does that leave the the mask
situation then
well we also set out the uh the details
in terms of masks
we are changing the rules in schools in
terms of the use of masks because we
know that schools
within school wearing a mask in lessons
for instance
uh it means that the lessons are it's
harder to communicate it's harder to
teach
but in in general settings we're keeping
the rules on the mask as they are
for this step outside of schools and you
know master
mask wearing is one of those things that
the the cost of it
uh to your personal sort of you know
going about your normal life is really
really small um we know that they
are of benefit and that's one of the
things we've learned you know one of the
things that scientists have
uh have uh have have developed the
science on and learned during the
pandemic
uh and so they'll those rules will be
staying the same except for within
school settings
so so the same up until so there's a
possibility at least that
the mask rule the mask mandate if you
like could
could go in june you haven't ruled it
out
well when it comes to when we haven't
ruled that out when it comes to the
the where where we end up on social
distancing rules
um and the anything to do with
um certification um domestically for
instance
for large events whether that goes ahead
that will all be set out ahead of step
four on monday we're taking step three
and then step four as you know
we've said will happen not before the
21st of june and between now and then
we'll monitor the data
and those four tests that the chief
medical officer set out so clearly
yesterday okay you mentioned
certification
where are we with that because you say
that maybe on the domestic front that's
that's going to come into play from june
but on an international travel front
that's going to come into play from next
monday
is the app it's meant to be all going on
to the nhs app is that going to be up
and running by next monday
yes the the um certification being able
to show that you've had a jab
is going to be necessary for people to
be able to travel
so we want to make sure people can get
access to that
proof not least to show governments of
other countries
that that you've had the job if they
require that
in order to arrive israel is a good
example they've said that they'll want
proof of you having had two jobs uh for
you to go to
uh to uh to israel as and when they open
up they're on the
green list of course so we will make
sure that you can get access to that to
prove that
point that is different to the question
of whether we
require people uh to be certified as
coveted secure before before doing
things domestically
that is something that michael gove is
working on and we're looking at these
pilots that are
that are running uh you saw that there
were you know there was an audience at
the crucible
uh for the snooker finals uh the brits
are going ahead
we're testing different ways that this
might work
for large events and then we'll be
following the science on that
but really the focus for you know for
the time being on this certification
question
is making sure that people can travel
internationally and show that they've
had the jab if that's what another
country requires
i'm sure your people at your end are
telling you that we're almost out of
time i just want to very quickly ask you
about the importance of vaccination
when are we going to move down to the 35
plus age group
yeah pretty soon pretty soon yeah we've
gone down to the
all 40s and above in the last couple of
weeks as you've seen the numbers of
vaccines is going
uh gangbusters more than 600 000 on
saturday
again and the number of first
vaccinations is actually rising at the
moment
and uh and we're getting through all
those critical second vaccinations
really important if you've got your
second jab then come forward at the time
that you're
asked to come forward uh people
everybody's doing it it's absolutely
fantastic to see the proportion of
people yeah
almost everybody uh unless they've got
some complicated logistical issue or
uh it's coming forward for their second
job so important
and we'll let you know as soon as we are
able to take that next step
uh to the uh to the under 40s okay good
to talk to you this morning thank you
thanks for having me on okay let's talk
to our political correspondent joe pipe
what do you think joe
pretty soon with the over 35s that's
because that's good news sounds like
that is
imminent things i was interested in were
on social care perhaps
a hint that there will be more details
in the queen's speech you didn't want to
be drawn on this too much to
sort of um prejudge what her majesty is
going to say we'll have to wait to hear
what she says he said but
this is a real priority for the governor
it has to be especially the funding we
do not know how social care will be
funded
uh government departments can't really
agree we need to get the opposition
you know and government agreeing because
in the past
there's been sort of political games uh
the conservatives called labour's plan
in called brown's uh premiership
a death tax remember theresa may during
the 2017 election that was the dementia
attacks they sort of do need to
agree on voter id interesting he was
saying that uh
you you put to the health secretary that
there are six cases of voter fraud at
the last general election
six cases are too many it's about
fairness it's perfectly reasonable to
ask for id
this though stephen very controversial
the election system in this country does
seem
very fair and it seems possible that
millions of people are potentially
disenfranchised if they don't have
id currently you just need your name and
address to
vote he didn't really explain what a
cautious hug was but i suppose it
depends on your
health risks your your vaccine status
and on
masks i think the message there is you
have to wait and see but possibly we
could get
rid of mars from the 21st of june we've
not ruled it out matt hancock said yeah
okay joe thank you well adam bolton is
going to be presenting full coverage of
the queen's speech
later this morning that coverage starts
at half past 10 bringing you all the
news and analysis of what legislation is
heading down the line
and how it will affect you
meanwhile a member of the sage committee
advising the government has warned next
week's easing of the lockdown
could lead to an increase in coronavirus
cases professor ian boyd from st
andrews university said we should not
become blase
well this is the latest situation and
according to the latest figures
there have been 2 357 new cases of
coronavirus
four more deaths have been reported
which brings the total number who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
to 127 609.
another 100 626 people have had their
first vaccination
and 187 171 have had their second so
that means
53.3 million injections have now been
given out
across the uk
still to come for you this morning the
leader of the liberal democrats will be
with us at
7 35 to tell us what he hopes to hear
in the queen's speech
and ahead of the speech and following
the labour reshuffle we'll also talk to
the shadow foreign secretary lisa nandy
that's at five past
eight and one of london's most famous
theaters
is this morning reveal what audiences
will see when they return
in a few months kate vara from london's
old vic will be with us
at a quarter to 10.
now world leaders have called for calm
after three days of clashes between
israel and the palestinians last night
rockets were fired by palestinian
militants from gaza which was followed
by
israeli air strikes sent back the other
way
well let's talk to our correspondent
aleister bunker
who joins us now i mean clearly there's
real concern now so that this is going
to continue to escalate
there is and i think one of the main
worries now is that it has moved from
street protests and the violence that we
saw uh over the past few weeks but
particularly heightened over the weekend
in and around the old city of jerusalem
and it's escalated to
a military level and you are seeing uh
both hamas
in gaza firing rockets out uh into
israel particularly worryingly
targeting jerusalem that's the first
time rockets have targeted jerusalem
for many years now and in return as
you'd expect
the israeli defense forces are
retaliating they've given a briefing
early this morning saying that more than
200 rockets were fired from
gaza some of those fell short and
actually
exploded in gaza itself but some
did hit targets um in and around
southern
israel in return these rays as i say
have fired back
using attack helicopters drones and
airstrikes from aircraft and they've
been hitting targets that they say are
legitimate
hamas military targets in gaza
more than 20 have been killed in gaza
including some children
the um hamas group say that civilians
have been killed
the israelis say they can't confirm or
deny that but they take every
uh effort possible uh to make sure that
civilian casualties are avoided so
where are we now well there's no obvious
flash point
today uh as there has been over the last
couple of days
but we wait to see whether or not these
retaliatory strikes will continue
uh and whether or not the israelis
probably want to continue striking
gaza to make a point and whether or not
hamas will continue to fire that
okay alistair for now thank you
now also making the headlines for you
this morning and a 21 year old man has
been charged with the murder
of the police community support officer
julia james in kent
callum wheeler from helsham is due to
appear in court today
the body of ms james was discovered in
woods two weeks ago
president biden said there's no evidence
of involvement from the russian
government over a cyber attack that
targeted the country's largest fuel
pipeline system
a ransomware attack forced colonial
pipeline to shut down on friday
but it's thought a criminal gang was
responsible
i'm going to be meeting with president
putin and
so far there is no evidence based on
from our intelligence people that russia
is involved although there's evidence
that the actors ransomware is in russia
they have some responsibility to deal
with this
doctors in the united states have
approved plans to give the fisa vaccine
to children aged
12 to 15. regulators called it a
watershed moment
in trying to bring the pandemic under
control
the u.s television network nbc has
joined the boycott of the golden globe
awards the committee organizing the
ceremony
has been criticized after it was
revealed they'd not included a black
member for 20 years
tom cruise has added to the backlash by
returning the three golden globes
that he's won during his career
meanwhile the brit awards will tonight
become the first big music event in more
than a year to have a live audience
about 4 000 people are expected to
attend the show
which is part of a government pilot
study claire gregory
reports the sight of crowds with no
masks and no social distancing
is now strangely unfamiliar but the
music industry hopes this won't be for
long
tonight a 4 000 strong crowd will head
here to the o2 to watch the brit awards
the first live indoor event of this
scale in over a year
it's all part of the government's pilot
scheme
there will be no social distancing so
that's going to be you know one of the
the best parts of tonight the reason we
can do that is because everybody coming
to the event
has to take a lateral flow test nhs
approved site
uh and demonstrate that they've got a
negative test result
data from a recent trial gig in
barcelona where people didn't distance
but did wear masks
showed no sign of higher rates of
coronavirus
[Music]
nominees hope tonight's show will help
prove this can be done
safely it's quite a privilege to be able
to go and
and have this as a test event and
perhaps it's it kind of takes on a
different
importance for that reason it's going to
be really nice just to
just to see people and you know human
beings are sociable animals and
it has been really tough for everybody
to be locked up so it's nice to get a
chance to go out and let our hair down
for a night
[Music]
it's been a record-breaking year for
women making up four of the five best
album nominees for the first time ever
a historically male dominated category
[Music]
this year's rising star winner hopes
it's a sign of change in the industry
it's exciting but also it's about time
you know i think everyone's been waiting
for it so
it's not it's not like this year with
the brits has just like kind of
given us courtesy like you know
nominations for girls it's actually just
that girls are killing it at the moment
and are
writing incredible music so it's about
time that it is actually just recognized
what it is
but no matter who walks away with awards
if tonight's ceremony means these eerily
empty venues will soon be full again
the fans will be the winners claire
gregory sky news
let's see what the weather's going to do
for you today morning nas how are we
looking
um pretty much the same as the last few
days in fact the same as last week but
the only difference is this week is not
as cold as the previous one
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning low pressure dominates the
weather this week so we are going to
continue with the unsettled theme of
showers or longer spells of rain but it
won't be as cold as it was
last week ins in fact this morning
slightly cooler than it was
yesterday morning not as mild as
yesterday morning so it's not a
completely frost free start in some
rural spots there is apache frost but
for many inland areas it's mainly dry
over parts of wales though and western
england there are some showers southern
island too
and across central and western parts of
scotland there are
cloudy skies and patchy outbreaks of
rain otherwise it's mostly fine
going into this afternoon the rain
across scotland continues to move its
way northwards so becoming drier and
brighter
there and across england and wales we're
seeing suede showers moving northwards
so widespread showers in between dry and
bright as well some of them heavy and
sundry
later particularly across northern and
northeastern parts of england
maybe the risk of hail later on and
there will be another area of showers
across the southwest of ireland
moving into the southwest of england and
wales with the heavy downpours by the
end of the day across parts of wales as
well
winds will be strong across the
southwest and across the far northeast
in fact it's generally breezy everywhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
yes thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast
we'll talk to the former conservative
cabinet minister damian green as the
government is expected to leave
reform of adult social care out of the
queen's speech today
there are things we all take for granted
as the rivers and tides flow
the sun will rise the wind will blow
and the earth will spin but are we now
spiraling into a climate crisis
which cannot be avoided no one can
predict the impact that it's going to
have
close to the peak here this is really
the moment of truth
expected to be hit very hard indeed
what can be done to reverse the spiral
the daily climate show on sky news
will look for the answers
it's taken me a long time to speak about
it
um you've become more comfortable the
more you speak about it i think and
it's helped my relationship you know
with my wife and everyone more open
and just talking helps and helping each
other out
you know like you say getting outdoors
is is very important for us as a family
that's why i teamed up with miracle grow
to try and help encourage the british to
get outside to pledge to spend more time
outside you can just go to their well
the website which is lovethegarden.com
you get their well-being journal when
you make a pledge
and it's full of recipes and lots of
ideas to help
and encourage people to enjoy some
outdoor space
it's just something that is always in
our life as a family we encourage each
other to get outside because it does
boost your mood and we find if we're
indoors too long
we become too too down and
it doesn't help with everyday activities
really
my wife jokes that she's lost me to a
leaf blower a hedge cutter a lawn mower
and a hose
pipe which uh i think is is a bit of an
exaggeration
but i find it very therapeutic and i was
watering the plants the other day
and i was busy and i asked frankie to do
it and she did it and she was very
surprised how much she enjoyed it and
it is just getting outside even if it's
for 10 minutes can boost your mood you
know when we were home schooling it was
let's get the kids outside and do
something for 10 20 minutes because it
does help
i'm 40 now but i probably wasn't open
till i was 38 and i wish i had been open
before
um i'm more open with my wife so our
relationship is better we pick each
other up a lot
and you know i speak to someone
professionally every now and again and
it helps and
you don't necessarily get they don't
necessarily have the answers but just
getting things off your chest can
can help so much
[Music]
[Music]
this is sky news breakfast now the
health secretary says the government
hasn't yet ruled out changing the rules
on masks next month
lockdown measures on mixing households
and
socializing will ease next monday but
speaking to us just a few minutes ago
matt hancock said the rules on masks
could be relaxed when restrictions are
reviewed again
in june mask wearing is one of those
things that
the the cost of it uh to your personal
sort of video
going about your normal life is really
really small
we know that they are of benefit and
that's one of the things we've learned
you know one of the things that
scientists have
uh have have developed the science on
and learned during the pandemic
and so they'll those rules will be
staying the same except for within
school settings
so so the same up until so there's a
possibility at least that
the mask rule the mask mandate if you
like could
could go in june you haven't ruled it
out
well when it comes to when we haven't
ruled that out when it comes to the
the where the where we end up on social
distancing rules
um and the anything to do with
um certification domestically for
instance
for large events whether that goes ahead
that will all be set out ahead of step
four on monday we're taking step three
now so far there's no indication the
government will fulfill its manifesto
promise to bring forward legislation on
adult social care
in today's queen's speech and i asked
the health secretary
whether or not it would be included we
will be bringing forward a
long-term plan for the reform of social
care
of course the pandemic struck a year and
a bit ago
and we've been totally focused on that
but as we come
out of covid so we can return to
delivering on those
manifesto commitments that we've made so
so
i mean we don't expect it to be part of
the queen's speech then so why
if it's so important why not
well you'll have to wait and hear what
her majesty says
you know and and you haven't heard what
she's going to say on this or indeed any
other subject but what i can tell you
is that we are committed to bringing
forward a plan
a long-term plan for the reform of adult
social care we've seen the importance of
social care through this
crisis and that has that has
if in my view strengthened the need for
reform the need for integration with the
nhs
and we also need to legislate to
strengthen the nhs so that the nhs can
can build back better from covid as well
well let's talk to the leader of the
liberal democrats ed davey who also has
some experience
actually of being a carer good to see
you this morning look
i think difficult to hancock being quite
tight-lipped
i mean not surprisingly but are you
expecting anything in the queen's speech
on this today
nowhere near enough um the government
have promised
time and time again that they'll fix the
problem with social care
and they fail to deliver we may hear a
bit about integration but nothing about
issues around
finance nothing about issues around
giving carers a break
nothing about issues about how we're
going to make sure that
the nhs understands that the care system
is crucial if you care about the nhs
you've got to care about care surely the
pandemic
has taught us that and what liberal
democrats have been championing
we need to be on the side of carers
whether they're paid
paid carers working in our care homes or
going to people's homes
or whether they're the unpaid carers
looking after loved ones
at home millions of them and the
government looks like it's going to
betray those carers who played such a
key role
in keeping people safe during this
covered pandemic
do you accept though that the delay in
bringing forward the legislation that
boris johnson promised back in 2019
i mean do you accept the the excuse if
you like that obviously there have been
some other big priorities up until now
no i don't there's been report after
report
about the solutions everyone knows where
the issues are
the most famous report was by sir andrew
dilnott
uh nearly a decade ago and indeed uh
i managed to with others legislate for
solutions which the government then
then dropped we had theresa may's
appalling plan which was going to force
people to sell their homes
and now the government have dithered and
delayed and meanwhile
millions of people are suffering
millions of people aren't getting the
care they need
means of families are having to sell
homes uh sell their
uh you know their assets um because
they're not getting support
that they were promised and you know if
boris johnson docks this today
and just tinkers at the edges with
structural change rather than
fundamental
change then i'm afraid liberal democrats
will be voting against this queen speech
i mean i'm concerned that what their
queen speech seems to be saying about
planning
which is going to make it a developer's
charter we need a community-led planning
system not a developer-led
planning system we can get the homes but
homes where the local people want
supported by new schools by new
hospitals not a developer's free-for-all
that the tourists seem to want
and there are other things that i really
worry about this queen's speech
but it'll be on social care we'll
liberal democrats are saying
we're the voice of carers people need to
get behind carers far more after the
pandemic and when we talk about building
homes that are needed they might be must
be community-led
not top down like the tourists seem to
want but as you've pointed out i mean
this is an issue that successive
governments have tried to tackle for
for many decades now the problem is you
talk about this this huge structural
change is actually very difficult and
potentially very very expensive there is
there is no quick fix here is there
well um actually there's lots of ideas
and lots of pilots and trials around the
country
it's the lack of political will and yes
there will be
more money and and no one should move
away from that
but surely if we're going to look after
people and care for them
and invest in our nhs and social care as
the government say they want to do
this is the moment to do it and you know
we've seen great examples of
local care sectors working with the nhs
the government just needs to
to act and it's this delay endeavor
and failure to deliver on promises which
i think is is really worrying people
and let's remember that there are prizes
here there's lots of people
who are left in hospital for weeks and
months costing a lot of money
not good for their health or their
well-being when if they organize the
care sector properly
and we have that proper integration that
proper finance then actually
we could unlock those beds as well as
giving people better care
the government are frankly incompetent
as well as delaying
look just before we let you go just just
very briefly i mean it's really good to
talk to you this morning but you and the
liberal democrats seem to have
virtually disappeared from daily
politics over the last 12 months
what's going on well and look at the
local elections we had some really good
results in key areas
you know whether it's cambridgeshire
oxford surrey hertfordshire wiltshire
chiefs we need to win off the tories at
the next election place like stockport
wokingham guildford
you know it was the liberal democrats
who were taking seats off the tories
people been talking about the red wall
in the north where the tories are
winning seats of labor
i think people should look at the blue
wall in the south where
it's the liberal democrats who are
taking seats off the conservatives
and the results we saw last thursday
were really heartening for liberal
democrats
because to be honest if you want to see
boris johnson out of 10 downing street
to the next election
if you want to see the conservatives
beat in the next election in many parts
of the country this is the liberal
democrats who can deliver
that for you david good to talk to you
thank you
well let's uh talk to the conservative
mp for ashford and the commissioner
of the government's social green uh
social care green paper
damien greene good to see you this
morning look
are you frustrated that that we'd have
certainly no indication that there is
going to be
anything substantial on adult social
care in the queen's speech today
well like everyone else i'm frustrated
that it's taken so long
uh to get to this stage um i i didn't
expect the full details in the queen's
speech
the the government produced a uh a white
paper
on integrating health and social care a
couple months ago and said they would
they would do it this year which i took
as a sign
that they're going to do it with the
comprehensive spending review
that we get in the autumn there's a
certain sense to that because that will
set out
spending figures for years to come
that's a more sensible time to do the
detail
than the queen's speech where you've got
a lot of a lot of other legislation as
well
but i am absolutely insistent that this
needs to be the year
uh for action and decision uh rather
than
kicking the can down the road any
further and what actually do you want to
see happen i mean ed davey they're
talking about
a sort of a comprehensive change to the
system there i mean
that has to be the case doesn't it
rather than just tinkering around the
edges
um it does i mean ed david was talking
about becoming the voice of carers
that's
that's the sort of empty sound by that
that doesn't advance the debate
i think you need to act first of all on
funding uh we need to find a way both to
get
more if you like public money in
taxpayers money and possibly through
uh people have suggested a national
insurance surcharge maybe
half percent on national insurance for
people over a certain age
also i think very much you should
encourage people
to save so that they can have some kind
of insurance policy of their own for old
age
but it's well it's about money it's not
just about money
we've got to do something for the
workforce we've got to give them a
proper career structure
we've got to change the way we house
elderly people we've got to
build houses that they can live in for
longer we've got to use
technology to enable them to stay at
home for longer
so you actually have less time if you if
you do need
the percentage of people who need
residential care who need to go into a
care home
we can reduce that with changes in
housing and technology
so we need this kind of holistic
approach rather than
only concentrate on the funding vital
that the funding is
yeah because we are i mean the
conservatives always sort of
put themselves as the party of of of
those who you know who want to aspire
who want to save who want to pass money
down the generations reducing
inheritance tax all these sort of issues
i mean the problem is at the moment
anyone going into social care or
anything they may want to pass down to
their children or grandchildren just
pretty much gets swallowed up in its
entirety
yeah exactly and and and the prime
minister was exactly correct when he
said the one thing he wants to stop is
people
uh having to sell their homes and and
the root of all this
is that we all agree you have to spend
more money on social care we've got a
slightly threadbare system now where
that money comes from is is why it's
proved so politically
difficult over the decades the first
prime minister to say we've got to deal
with this with tony blair 25 years ago
it's
been a very long running small now uh so
people have to accept that we are all
going to have to pay some more money
how you do that is is the key way and
one of the things you have to do is to
say
um there is some kind of cap on the
costs so
that you won't have to sell your family
home and give up all your wealth for
most people that's the vast bulk of
their wealth
give up all of that so you've got
nothing to hand on to your children
i mean forgive me for jumping in but i
mean when you when you mention
you know certainly something you know
half a percent increase of
for some people over a certain age on
national insurance or
some sort of insurance scheme that they
can join
that may well be a sensible way forward
clearly i haven't seen any details but
that leaves a a big gap doesn't it of
those people who are already in their
later years who aren't going to be able
to access any of that
yeah i think that there are those who
obviously it's as it were too late for
them to start saving
and and that's why you're going to need
uh extra
straightforward taxpayers money as well
as all of that because what i want to
see
this reform do is not just address the
immediate problems which of course
are crucial but also set up
a stable and sustainable long-term
system so you'll have to do all of this
at once
and the root of it is is that we are all
one way or another going to have to pay
for this and the reason it's difficult
is that if people when confronted by
this as they were in say the 2017
election campaign say well we don't want
to pay you any more for this
um and i'm afraid it's going to have to
be an act of political bravery
to say you are going to have to pay more
for this if you want to be
in social care for yourself or for your
your parents or so on
now what's the best and fairest way to
do that that's where
the debate should center over the next
few months
damian greene good to talk to you this
morning thank you
thank you now a controversial plan to
introduce an amnesty for alleged
offences by british soldiers who served
in northern ireland before the good
friday agreement is expected to be
confirmed in the queen's speech today
the timing coincides with the findings
of an inquest due to be published later
into the deaths of 10 civilians shot
dead where members of the parachute
regiment opened fire
in bali murphy in 1971. our senior
island correspondent
david blevins reports
it is a neighborhood still haunted by
the events of three days in august 1971.
ten civilians were killed when members
of the parachute regiment opened fire in
bally murphy
the dead included a catholic priest two
teenagers and a mother of eight children
the last words my mummy said was the
army wouldn't shoot you mommy wouldn't
hurt you so she felt she was safe
the victims families say no one should
be above the law
she'd break-read her she had a coat
sandals a dress on that could say very
easily that she was a woman
and not only that they fired at her
but the first shot was aimed straight at
her face
now to me that's personal
belfast was an uproar the detention of
ira suspects without trial
causing serious unrest the army reported
a gun battle in valley murphy
but none of the victims there was armed
that's where
where mrs conley was going when she was
shot to help this young man crown out
the soldier walked over to him the army
officer and
executed him he had a bullet behind each
year
john's dad was shot 14 times he's still
campaigning for justice i i thought i
was a hardened campaigner
until the evidence started coming out
in court in detail we'll post more
post-mortem
things like that the right and it was
really hard for all of us
to sit sit through that really hard
five months later the parachute regiment
shot 14 people dead on bloody sunday in
londonderry
the battalion on duty in derry had come
from bally murphy
had these shootings been properly
investigated at the time
bloody sunday may not have happened five
months later
in other words what happened here set in
motion a train of events
that would come to be known as the
northern ireland troubles
the inquest findings are due on the very
day the government's expected to confirm
a halt to historical prosecutions author
brian rowan has written extensively
on how northern ireland might address
its troubled past
i think the only way out of this is an
amnesty that's the only way to truth
or more information it's the word we
will not speak
it's too it's too poisonous but if we
don't go there
then we aren't going to have a legacy
process
or a truth process and with the wars
over we're going to spend the next 30
years fighting the peace it's not that
they don't want to move on here
it's that their loved ones were never
given that opportunity
david blevins sky news in bali murphy
world leaders have appealed for calm
after days of violent clashes between
israel and the palestinians rockets were
fired towards jerusalem by palestinian
militants
in response israel launched air strikes
into the gaza strip officials there
say 20 people were killed there are very
grave violations of international law
occurring
that there is a disproportional use of
force against palestinians
all of the casualties all of the deaths
are palestinian it's it's not enough to
say let's de-escalate as if
all of these palestinian lives are not
worth
you know a pause at the very least uh an
expression of
of sincere regret and condolence
none of that is happening and without
consequence
let me just put it that way without
consequence for violations of
international law
this uh this trap will continue
this reality will not cease and that's
just
untenable well let's talk to
hen masik an israeli writer and former
israeli defense force
humanitarian officer good to see you
this morning
all these world leaders now calling for
calm
will any of that be heard on either side
do you think
i think that the situation right now is
very emotionally charged
um we are uh you know right after
jerusalem day
nakba day is coming this saturday so
people are using it as an excuse to
promote violence
unfortunately and i think that we will
see more violence coming um
and it's coming from all sides so i
think at this point uh the most
important thing to do
is to de-escalate and to stop uh the
violence the violence started
um last week with the murder of israeli
teenager
um you da guetta that was murdered by
palestinian terrorists
and his both friends were shot so
responding to what we heard before
uh um the israeli civilians have been uh
the ones that were
um um you know going through going under
rocket attacks and and being um shot and
yesterday we heard calls in in al-aqsa
mosque
to bomb tel aviv um so the situation is
uh
indeed very very tense right now but i
mean
it is always a very difficult situation
when we talk about
the the tensions between israel and the
palestinians but certainly from
from our correspondent on the ground was
saying some of the skirmishes over the
last couple of days around the al-aqsa
mosque
seem to have been unprovoked and and the
the police force the idf
seem to be you know taking the lead on
on provoking some of that violence
uh i'm not sure um if the idf was the
one provoking i think that
once you know these are not protests
like protests that we're seeing in
london or in in america
these are violent protests yesterday a
man a jewish man was almost
lynched driving his car in jerusalem by
a mob of palestinian
activists that were throwing blocks on
him
as i said just a week before um
[Music]
a teenage boy israeli boy was killed
and the situation has just escalated
since then the protests themselves are
not just protests of you know holding
signs and
enchanting anything uh peaceful it's
it's violent
um protests uh using blocks trying to
harm civilians
and um as we've seen overnight i mean my
mom told me that
um rockets were barraged on israel
over 200 rockets and and it's important
that we look at those rockets for what
they are each rocket is an attempt to
attempt to murder israelis
these are not just you know imagine
going into a an audience
in london somewhere with a with a gun
and just shooting 200 times
the fact that uh we have the defense
system like the iron dome that is uh
protecting israeli civilians
doesn't mean that those rockets are not
an attempted an attempt to murder and
hamas also has a way
to stop the violence uh in gaza and stop
the um
the the airstrikes of israel um it's
just called
to stop shooting rockets i mean you
talked in your first answer about the
importance of de-escalation that has to
come from
from both sides what can israel do what
can the israeli
parliament do on the basis you know it
does seem to be pretty unstable at the
moment with
with the problems that mr netanyahu is
facing
yeah you're absolutely right uh stephen
i think the israeli government has taken
a few
um a few actions a few steps there
yesterday first of all the the
court decision that was supposed to come
um this week was postponed in 30 days
to uh to ease the tension um jews were
barred from
going up to the temple mount um uh this
uh yesterday morning and i think today
as well
uh jerusalem day parade was uh rerouted
and instead of going through damascus
gates in jerusalem
because we rooted to go to through a
different path to um to avoid tension so
israel has taken steps to um to
calm down the the flames um but
i think that what we're seeing is the
other side the hamas in gaza and
and the terrorists i mean it's not only
in gaza also in jerusalem
that the rockets were accepted with
cheers and that's
that has to stop okay mazaki it's good
to talk to you thank you
thanks so much okay let's have a quick
look at the weather for you now with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways good morning
we are
seeing low pressure dominate the weather
this week so we continue with
unsettled theme of showers or longer
spells of rain this afternoon is going
to be a case of sunshine and
showers showers moving northward some
heavy and thundery later across parts of
northern and northeastern
areas of england and the southwest will
also see some showers later rain
clearing northwards across scotland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways